así
ya conocemos las coordenadas de algunos
puntos especiales cuando los rotamos
pero para crear las herramientas de
software para las tomas
necesitamos fórmulas que nos digan a
dónde se van todos los puntos cuando los
rotamos es decir si empezamos con un
punto arbitrario xy nos gustaría saber
las coordenadas x prima de prima del
punto al que llegan después de la
rotación las fórmulas que vamos a
encontrar no son muy complicadas
de hecho las tenemos aquí x prima es
igual a x x coseno beteta menos de
porsche no detecta que prima es igual a
x por seno detectan más que por coseno
de teta así es que si conocemos los
valores de x xi y theta podemos calcular
x prima y ye prima pero de dónde vienen
estas fórmulas bueno hay varias formas
de obtener estas fórmulas una es usar
las propiedades de las transformaciones
lineales
otra forma más elemental para derivar
estas fórmulas consiste en usar las
definiciones básicas de la trigonometría
y nos va a costar un poco de trabajo
encontrarlas
así es que prepara tus manos y tu
cabello
llamémosle p al punto en el que
empezamos y p primer al punto al que
llega cuando lo rotamos necesitamos
construir algunos otros puntos para que
nos ayuden así es que regresemos a lo
que ya sabemos y resolvamos el problema
por partes primero rotamos el diagrama e
imaginemos que el pp es el eje x esto se
ve como la situación que vimos en el
vídeo pasado cuando rotamos el punto 10
que se encontraba sobre el eje x así es
que dibujamos una perpendicular desde el
punto prima hasta el eje x y así es como
definimos al punto
invertimos la rotación y ahora dibujamos
una perpendicular desde el punto a hasta
el eje x y así definimos al punto b y de
la misma forma dibuja una perpendicular
desde el punto prima hasta el eje x y
así encontramos hace
y observa que la coordenada x
o sea la línea v es más grande que la
coordenada x de p prima o sea la línea
11 por lo que tenemos que restar cierta
cantidad y la cantidad que tenemos que
restar es la longitud de la nueva línea
a de ahora recuerda que las coordenadas
que queremos encontrar son las de p
prima que están definidas en x por la
longitud osce y en g por la longitud de
prima c pero bueno finalmente dibuja una
perpendicular desde el punto p hasta el
eje x y así definimos el punto y ahora
si este diagrama tiene toda la
información que necesitamos practiquemos
un poco con este diagrama derivando
algunas fórmulas que vamos a necesitar
más adelante supongamos que r es la
distancia desde el origen hasta p y
digamos que fi es el ángulo que se forma
entre p y el eje x
la distancia ep s y la distancia
es x ep es el lado opuesto a fin
entonces el seno de fi es igual a ep / r
pero el pp es igual a jr
entonces el seno de fi es igual hay
entre r y eso significa que es igual a r
por seno de fi de forma similar
es el lado adyacente a fi entonces el
coche no de fi es igual a
/ r pero es igual a x
entonces el coseno de fitch es igual a x
entre r y eso significa que x es igual a
r por coseno de fi
wow eso sí que fue un montón de
trigonometría bueno pero antes de
continuar contesta algunas preguntas
sobre este diagrama en el próximo
ejercicio buena suerte